statuses of Heroes foreboding hints at
the future and blasts from the past the
new trailer for The Mandalorian is
filled with blink and you miss the
details with the Star Wars sequel
Trilogy wrapping up lucasfilm and Disney
turned their attention to streaming in
2019 they came out of the gate Swinging
with the Disney plus exclusive the
Mandalorian which swiftly took the
television World by storm not only were
audiences fascinated by the mysterious
Mandalorian Bounty Hunter din jarin but
they couldn't get enough of his lovable
sidekick grogu it only made sense that
the following year a second batch of
episodes arrived for season 2 Series
Creator John Favreau went above and
beyond for Star Wars fans Boba Fett
returned from the grave Cobb Vance
jumped from print to TV and animated
icon Ahsoka Tano finally appeared in a
live-action production he even snuck in
Luke Skywalker for good measure the bar
is set incredibly high for season 3 and
the creators of the Mandalorian are
working overtime to keep viewers glued
to their screens following an intriguing
first trailer a new one premiered on
January 16th 2023 here are some of the
small details you might have missed a
Locale we get quite familiar with
throughout the first season of the
Mandalorian is Navarro it serves as a
refuge for bounty hunters thieves and
general miscreants the town is riddled
with run-down buildings and takes on a
generally gloomy appearance it improves
in the second season thanks in large
part to its magistrate grief carga
before Navarro became a sprawling
Metropolis in the making remnants of the
Galactic Empire tore it up in pursuit of
denjarin and grogu DIN and his allies
did a great job running the Empire out
of town with one character making the
ultimate sacrifice to save everyone in
chapter 8 Redemption ig-11 used its
self-destruct capability to annihilate
the Imperial troops in the new trailer
it's clear that to honor the Assassin
droid's memory karga has erected a
statue of ig-11 in the Square but just
because Navara was thriving doesn't mean
that the entire galaxy is as the
Mandalorian season 3 teaser continues we
learn that there's trouble on the
horizon speaking to denjarin Fan
Favorite Captain Carson Teva has some
ominous words something dangerous
happening out there and by the time it
becomes big enough for you to act
it'll be too late what could the X-Wing
pilot be alluding to he's likely talking
about the Imperial Remnant between moff
Gideon's desire to use grogu for
unspecified experiments to his
development of the dark Troopers it's
apparent there's still a lot to be
worried about and based on what the Star
Wars sequel Trilogy revealed the rise of
the first order the introduction of
supreme leader snoke and the return of
Emperor Palpatine are close at hand Teva
has every reason to be on his toes
another potential reveal also occurred
in the new trailer as we hear Carson
teva's Bleak voice over we see an
unknown character sitting on a ship next
to a Droid they seem to be on a planet
dominated by large buildings and
blinding lights at first glance this
location looks incredibly similar to
Coruscant Coruscant was a key location
throughout the prequel Star Wars Trilogy
it also featured quite prominently on
multiple animated shows various books
video games and more most recently it
appeared on Andor where Rebel leaders
Mon mothma and Lucin rail work to
undermine the Empire from right under
its nose as denjarin attempts to connect
with his Mandalorian Roots it should
come as no surprise that the Mandalorian
season 3 is set to include several more
of the mysterious Warriors throughout
the trailer we see a few unrecognizable
mandalorians and some we've seen before
such as Paz Vizsla the number of
mandalorians is rifled only by the
number of droids we see which range from
your run-of-the-mill astromex 2 protocol
droids of varying color and make even a
few B1 battle droids show up a handful
of them can be seen in a shot that seems
to depict a bunch of droids hanging out
in a bar or a mechanic shop of some kind
these flimsy robots were Staples of the
Star Wars prequel trilogy they were
destroyed in droves by clones and Jedi
alike at the command of separatist
leaders the Mandalorian season 3
premieres on Disney Plus on March 1st
[Music]
foreign